and you know we ready welcome back
absolutely ladies gentlemen welcome back
to riffle Griffin and today we got a
another special guest we don't fire
these days with the guest you know had a
stevie-baby we gotta get Adam Devine the
twitch channel is blowing up make sure
you check that out at Eric twitch.tv air
Griffin gaming and also YouTube air
Griffin gaming and right now we got
another tremendous guest that's right
y'all mr. Tom Segura yes it is we got
mr. Tom Segura from your mom's house you
know and the great special ball hog
which we talked about and so yeah I'm
really I'm really glad you took some
time to come on and you know give me a
ring and we did it you know we're trying
to do the best we can during these crazy
times and the show must go on
the content must keep coming so and I
appreciate all the love and support so
please share subscribe and hit the
notifications and you know tell your
friends about me tell your friends about
me and let's keep the show growing cuz
we will get back to normal we will I
know it and then you know it'll be like
we never stopped in terms of like you
know this podcast and just speaking for
me but anyways I hope you enjoyed it's a
great interview give it up for mr. Tom
Segura okay here we go
anyways welcome to this show calling
with Griffin and this is mr. Tom Segura
how you doing buddy
good to see you um let me just get to
the big stuff first I got cuz it's been
like two weeks now and I'm seeing all
these great articles about your special
ball hog
I mean hey what do you what do you think
about it like like like you came out
with a quarantine special I didn't even
know it and that could be one of the
last specials we see in that format for
a long time like what how do you feel
about that it's it's really strange
because as the quarantine started is
when I was like oh like we're all gonna
be at home and then as it you feel
bizarre to be like when I was promoting
it heavily you know like yeah like oh
yeah make sure you watch it and then
everyone keeps telling you aren't you
like are you excited and you're like
well it's it's a yeah it's kind of a
strange excitement to be like I'm so
glad people are terrified and out of
work right now no I know it's like it's
like it's such a first world problem for
you to be like it you know it's like hey
I guys be safe out there but also check
out my special yeah you know what I mean
it definitely throws and then this was
the first time in like the whole time
I've had a relationship with Netflix
where they gave me a report on the
performance you know like but since it's
the first time you have nothing to
compare it to so then I was you I go
well what does that mean like how did it
how did it do versus the last one and
they're like oh yeah ya know it smashed
it I was like okay great I guess I know
what are you supposed to say like that
you know it's like I don't know just
wants to like you know to read yeah it's
funny cuz you just I mean you said it
but you know nothing will be shot now
for months so yeah whatever was shot up
until you know a month ago that's it
that's all it's in the can so there yeah
there will be no there will be no like
stand-up specials that are shot or come
out after a certain point here for a
while yeah I think Chris D'Elia might be
the last one that's gonna come out on
Netflix yeah I haven't heard of I don't
I mean there might be obviously another
one or two in the can that we don't know
about why that's true that's true
I don't know but yeah after that that'll
be it for a while I know and who knows
when it will even come back
that format in a sense of like you look
out into a crowd of thousands of people
or hundreds of whatever how many it is
sitting right next to each other to like
who knows when that's gonna be like that
again I mean it's just I think that
Evers we will not see live entertainment
get back to where it was until they go
like here's the vaccine like you see
yeah
dude I've been saying the same thing
I've been saying the same thing now for
a couple of weeks just I even talked to
like a Dane Cook said to said this to me
he was like you know I it was like we're
not gonna be back until there's a
vaccine our business is gonna be shut
down and it's just it's hard to even
think about I mean isn't it weird to
fathom that like four weeks ago we had
all these plans and tours planned and go
to the Comedy Store every other night
and and now here we are like you know
people coming to your hike a studio you
know I mean like it's all these kind of
things that is just like like out of
nowhere it's such a bizarre thing to
live through and I still like I think
about that um I had to show March 12th
March 13th March 14th that I cancelled
right I rescheduled and we were
scheduled them for April at the time I
just put him in April yeah and they I
think they moved them to June and then I
talked to my agent yesterday and he
sounded so sad man yeah I know he was
like that like even like a week or two
ago he was like talking about the summer
definitely the fall and then now he's
like we have all these tour plan for
2021 yeah like I don't even know if
that'll happen I know and it's just like
and also I think there'll be a mad
scramble because I think people will
want this I mean cuz III appreciate how
people are loving like this you know
whatever you put out like I put out
these pop but I've put out more content
now than I ever have yeah people you
know I get these great messages from
people like oh man I really appreciate
this and these times I'm bored and I'm
depressed and you're really helping me
so I mean people want to entertainment I
mean it's like I you know I miss sports
I miss going to the movies you know I
mean all these kinds of things but yeah
who knows when it's really gonna be a
comedy clubs gonna be open again or a
stadium so I said there'll be a mad dash
like all them all the big tour acts
I don't know if I don't know if they'll
be back in Thousand Cedars anymore it
might be everybody's gonna be in the
comedy club again until like we don't I
mean it might be I mean I know then you
think of like you know the biggest
entertainment are our major sports you
know yeah oh I miss sports so much I
know like you know will 20,000 in a
basketball arena or a hundred thousand
in a football stadium want to do that I
mean it's really you know the NBA thing
was obviously a mate like it's a it's
unprecedented incomprehensible to
imagine the NBA season getting cut short
and then right at NFL coming up and
you're like no [ __ ] like this this also
might not take place you know I know and
I watch a lot of like those debate shows
first take a PTI and all those kind of
shows and it's funny to watch them
acting like everything's gonna be fine
in a month you know like the way they're
talking about football every morning
they're like Tom Brady's in Tampa and
it's like we may never see that like Tom
Brady may never play football again
because the season will be canceled I
know what I mean I totally agree with
you and I I think like the thing is I
want those people to be right this is
one of those times where I'm like yeah
whatever you're right I really do I want
it I always felt like like what we're
going through was unimaginable because
living in this era with technology and
information and just such brilliant
minds that know how to resolve
everything you could not I would never
believe that this would be a possibility
yeah yeah well being like just stay home
that's our spec that's the solution just
I know it's so weird to say well they're
basically saying like yo while we're
figuring this out can y'all just chill
for like three months
yeah just chill out for three months
even though I kind of believed it like I
think the world I think that every year
the whole world should shut down for a
week anyway I know there there's there
is like this weird part of this that is
like enjoyable to a degree you know what
you mean not the part where people
losing their jobs and we're not being
in unsympathetic to that we're just
saying that like trying to find the
silver lining in it is what we're saying
right I know exactly what you but also
like that like feeling the hustle die so
that like it's like it's like everyone's
saying like don't worry about I'm saying
more specifically to what we do but like
don't worry about your auditions or
yours yeah just live life for a moment
that part I mean is like you're like oh
yeah you know like I'm enjoying I'm
enjoying stuff with my family more I was
gonna say how have you adjusted how has
it been cuz for me did I just tell you
for me personally at first it was very
difficult like my girlfriend's with me
and like you know we're we're I got was
ring shopping and like think before this
all happened so I was really I'm really
serious but this kind of like really
puts you in there like can you live with
this person can you like it's really
like you know it's really giving me a
perspective and so the first couple of
days I'm gonna be thankful like week it
was I was like oh [ __ ] this is really
difficult but now I'm in a groove and
we're great but like how was it for you
like you've been married for how long
now you've been guys
almost 12 years right right right so you
already you are your D whatever you just
like about her usse already they're just
like but I think I've been saying that I
think this highlights the reality of
your relationship so if you're with
buddy you're compatible with your gonna
be like you know what we are super
compatible this really does work Brian
that's why man I talked to a couple
people that that agree they think that
when this does and you're gonna see the
ocean of divorces Oh will that happened
in China did you see that article about
that yeah it already happened in China I
was like four times five times as many
divorces coming out of their quarantine
I did not know that yeah man so of
course you know imagine that puzzle
person stuck in a let's say the person
who's married and their regular routine
is like they go to work maybe they take
business trips and they they don't
really get along but they're like yeah
you know it's just I can deal with it
because I don't to see you that much and
I do I do all these other things
and then this happens and they're like
no no no stay in a home with that person
and don't leave at all for like 90 [ __ ]
or in we don't even have to be so morbid
about it it even could be if you have a
routine and you don't even realize that
you're not near this significant other
because of the cuz of your life routine
she works you work you know like our
business we travel and then we come back
we we take time to miss each other
and then when you see each other again
you're like oh it's good to see you you
know it's just like you know when you're
just there all the time even the great
relationship may not be prepared for
what this is what this is I mean how do
you think what would you be what would
your advice be for somebody just marry
12 years I think man like I mean I can
only go through like our day you know we
have two little kids so our day is about
routine you know like spoke out you so
it's it's it's basically like making
this like a family function for us and
we've just been fortunate that like
everyone's healthy and you know we do we
do the thing like we get up you have
breakfast you get two kids ready video
yeah you just kind of my girl wears
different outfits it's crazy like she
gets up and she puts on like she puts on
like I go why are you looking all cute
today where we go man under me but it's
like but I totally get it
dude I think that's important I think
yeah you know what Christina did my wife
ordered wigs and she I got really horny
I really thought a wig a wig changes
somebody's appearance completely like
yeah you the face looks different with a
wig on like an eye yeah yeah yeah I was
like let's let's get there I'm finding
out things I didn't know I was supposed
to find out like I'm finding out like
what kind of porn she like sometimes now
that you know what I mean it's like you
know I mean I'm like oh okay you know me
so it's like but but I don't know about
you but like I at first was it was hard
for me I was feeling like a little bit
of depression because of like this like
lack of creative release you know that
we have all the time I felt pent up and
I feel like
I feel you slob in my cooking you know
I've been cooking and washing hand
washing the dishes and like you know cuz
I just need like I feel like I need
something to do and so that's why I
started this you know like how was that
for you
III try to do a bunch of things like I
try to go for a walk every day yeah I
work out at home I've even done like
virtual training you know like probably
so I try to exercise and then since I
know we can't do stand-up
I've been I've been writing things that
like it's not stand up but just writing
yeah it feels like you're actually
creatively working towards something
yeah you know oh and I've actually been
interacting I've been more social in
quarantine than I ever am in regular
life like I've called more people
FaceTime more people I've been going on
IG live like like saying hi to people I
don't know it's made me more social well
I mean look I've been saying this a lot
too is that before this happened people
especially young people think that this
is enough yeah they're on their snapchat
they're on the Instagram they're on it
and they think like oh this is the only
interaction I need and you old people
don't understand like this is how we
communicate now now all those
[ __ ] are like realizing oh this
isn't enough it's not enough we need
social interaction we're communal
creatures and we need to actually look
see touch smell it's just part of who we
thought of like who we are man does it
make you think about at all because we
see those stories in the news all the
time about especially in prisons when
somebody's in isolation and they go you
know it it can make them really lose
their minds
I start yeah about isolation in that
sense because the stories are always so
sad then you're like God like they're
like you throw a dude in the hole for 30
days and they come out like a different
person because they have like Oh human
interaction and then you've been
thinking about how there's a bunch of
people probably just like normally
lonely people but they at least have
access to other people if they want to
we're kind of like in this forced
quarantine you know
own and it makes me go like Jesus that
could really have a damn yeah man like I
feel like look look you know I think
people in the entertainment business and
like you know entertainers you know
above middle class sort of like wealthy
or people to like are not having the
same Quarantine experience you know and
it's like it's something to really be
like sensitive to I saw Lady Gaga
talking about this too you know where
she was like look we're not like the
economy and even like for me on a
smaller level of me not I'm not I'm not
struggling I wasn't poor or anything
like that but I saved my money but I
only but it's like maybe if this goes a
year I'll be okay but after that what do
I do for money I don't know I mean I'm
in a situation with your but still I'm
there's other people who were like they
lost everything right now looks like but
but so I I feel like our isolation is
different from like and even in
different cities like if you think about
New York who New York is so compact like
everybody you know those these little
apartments and these little you know
what I mean it's like I can't even
imagine cuz I feel stir-crazy and I have
an upstairs and downstairs you know I
mean III we forget it a lot I actually
thought she made an excellent point yeah
her point I mean look is that you could
make an argument that this is like
semantics about like when you say like
you know we're all on this together
because we are we we all have to you
know we're all doing the same thing but
we're not we're not we're all having
that we're not all having the same
experience yeah and then her point was
like as Lady Gaga her quarantine looks
way different than like someone who was
a bartender you know or like whatever a
city worker who's out of work now and is
like desperate because they don't know
what's gonna happen next and they can't
pay their bills it's a different thing
and yeah I totally get that man but it's
all relative though I mean it's like it
doesn't take away two person's
experience so yeah I saw one of these
rappers Tyger Tyger whatever his name is
and he's in his mansion and he's on like
a not a Segway but one of those one of
those scooter things things yeah yeah
and he's spinning around his living room
and he's all like I'm so bored he's on
this big marble
they're doing like a beat and he's
rapping like I'm bored I'm bored and I'm
thinking to myself like bro you are
bored but then there's people who
sitting in their little whatever looking
at their phone like goddamn I wish I was
there with you of course it's all
relative right
it's all relative man yeah man craziness
dude but like I'm looking at I was
looking at before I call it before we
got on I was just looking at that you
really are getting a lot of great
articles about your special really I
stopped I usually love you don't you
can't look at that [ __ ] but you know
purpose of this I am and will be like I
read this and I read that and I'll read
a couple but then I go like I don't want
to do like a deep dive and find out what
everybody thinks all right right but do
you feel misunderstood though like some
of the characterization is like it's
like this one says Tom Segura is trying
to upset you with his Netflix special
ball hawk and it's hilarious like when
you hear that is that accurate
or are you like no I'm just cuz I that's
a comic I know what you mean you like
you say something that somebody goes I
can't believe you're trying to say this
about that he was like no I thought that
was funny and I said that that should be
like every interview is like I thought
it was funny but yeah yeah there's not
like a big game plan or ever they asked
some of these journalists ask questions
and you're like I did all this press and
I was like Jesus I think they think is
way deeper you know you just want to go
like can we get to the part where I I
just thought that this story was funny
yeah and this interaction was funny and
I put it together in a long funny way
story I don't man but you know you know
what I find it's the difference between
like you know especially in the last say
10 years like what we do in the club's
live performance it's such a different
experience that for them from what we're
doing and putting in a broadcasting it
to like the mass public it's somehow it
isn't it weird how it's perceived
differently oh it's totally perceived
differently yeah it's completely
perceived differently I mean I don't
know man it's like when we're at the
Comedy Store every night you just feel
like
I feel like most of the people they are
just like you guys are a good time
you're yeah we just came here to laugh
and that's what you guys do you make us
laugh and I don't know even like we all
talk to each other about that's a good
bit that's a funny angle it's it's like
it's not that serious just as it should
be right like we shouldn't be
we're not serious that's the whole point
we're not serious yeah yeah and then I
don't know for some like part of it is
is like we're actually dealing with that
those huge articles that are breaking it
down because it's so popular
like if Stan diked popular nobody would
care to write those articles so it's
almost like we're like alright I mean
this thing got such huge exposure that
now you know there's people are writing
their thesis on on what we do but I
think they look at it way more like
academically than weed yeah yeah that's
when you say that but I know I agree
with you but there's also a time like
okay so I remember when Leslie Jones got
on SNL yeah and she was doing some bits
that she does and her stand up at the
club and then she did she's on the news
the the what did that the breaking news
thing they do on SNL and she did one of
her like bits and got a lot of flack for
it because of what she was saying and
I'm just thinking to myself damn if
these if you at the club you would see
her doing it at the club I mean I'm just
saying this strange how like we could be
at the club doing these bits even racier
bits even like you know challenging like
you know whatever we're talking about
gay transgender or politics religion
then you as soon as you put it on tape
and more than a hundred people watch it
at home but they'd have Twitter all of a
sudden it turns into like you're the you
can become like the worst person ever
you like a small group of people right
as the people who are always watch this
on tape never watch it in the clubs yeah
it's like you're showing it to people
who don't enjoy that on a regular basis
and asking them to like weigh in on it
you know I mean like like that
that bit you could do that bit in front
of 5000 people and kill and everybody
walks out of there being like that was
great but when you broadcast it people
see it who don't digest that type of
thing normally and then they have it
like they weigh in on what's wrong with
it like I remember that I remember the
Leslie Jones thing I think wasn't it
like something like like slaves made me
or solid like she was like descendants
and yeah something like that it's good
the way she does it it's all about her
performance yeah you know you don't mean
it didn't deserve that kind of treatment
the opposite it was so funny like yeah
oh I remember that it was like such a
surprise line I was like I saw I saw
that there was like people were talking
about I watched it and I was like this
is hilarious I never I don't know I'm
just like I said I'm just trying to like
not go stir-crazy right now yeah that's
you know it's just I don't know what's
even it's hard to describe think outdoor
walks at all yeah but I was about to say
you you said that I taking a walk I feel
like California was like saying to us
hey [ __ ] you
because it started to rain you know what
I mean I think it's like California was
like yo keep your ass inside and we're
gonna make it rain you know dreary out
here ain't the rain rain dead
quarantines can be a bummer a real
bummer no oh my god dude it's just it's
just bananas man and then and standing
outside feels good on these days you
know dude I want to get to mail and I
was just like I felt I felt like I
wasn't that in a movie and I've been
locked up for like ten years
yeah you know those scenes in the movie
when a guy gets out I felt like that I
was like I like just some beat down on
me and then you had this did you see
what do you think about that thing about
like the mayor put out that thing like
he's encouraging snitching
now that's wack dude that's as that is
not cool at all I mean my whole thing is
like who's gonna determine like like you
saw is everybody gonna be making a
citizen's arrest like hey what are you
doing out you gotta be like no I have to
tell everybody my business yeah my mom
to mention and I gotta go see her you
know me like what it like you know what
I mean it's a bad thing to try to get
going like you know rat on people but
but yeah there's so many questions about
how you would enforce it but also those
[ __ ] [ __ ] exist anyways like yeah
we kinda tattletale on people they're
the worst
do another seminal a friend's a doctor
that she was at the grocery store and
they have a line like a they put like a
tape orange yeah yeah yeah
so she was standing behind it and then
the guy was standing at the register
buying his groceries and the guy turned
around was like can you stand further
back she was she looked at it she was
like I'm behind the line and like we we
have the distance between us he was like
you know you should go back even further
and she was like no yeah like [ __ ] you
they told the cashier he was like can
you tell her so that I don't have to and
but it's in front of her so she goes uh
he doesn't have I I hear you and yeah
I'm not moving anymore oh man I I feel
like I feel like there's a certain
personality and they're usually like I
don't want a stereotype but a lot of
times they're like white ultra-left
hippie people the worst people yeah
don't they like okay so I'm at 7-eleven
the other day I just I'm grabbing just
trying to get some drinks get the hell
out of there I got my mask on whatever
you know I got you I wear a scarf so I
look like I'm robbing the place you know
I mean they this guy's innocent so I see
I come outside and there's a guy in this
car and he's saying something to another
guy who's got a mask on but the guy in
the mask
he starts scolding the guy in the car
you know you shouldn't be out in public
without a mask he's going on and on and
on and I'm thinking to myself wow like
is this your gonna do that [ __ ] to the
wrong person of course you are you know
you don't I mean yeah it's like your
business or more of a danger to the
white hippie guy
who does that then because like women
for the most part you know they could
mouth off about something and people are
just like calling the manager it's like
white women do that in a restaurant I
need to see the manager and we just kind
of go okay everybody back away but yes
yes - guys I agree the dude can get
might get if he says it to the wrong
person is gonna get clocked in the face
men yeah I just I just think it's it's
one thing to come up to like if you're
in a restaurant not even a restaurant or
like you're in a store are you in some
kind of like place where this is like a
lot of people all right then it's like
hey I think you should wear a mask
because you know it says it in the thing
you could say something there's like a
time in place but the way this guy was
scolding this guy I was like yo get off
your moral high ground man no I know
it's a weird I don't know how to feel
about it but I just feel like this is
gonna create some like weirdness yeah
there's everything together everything
in the recipe right now is gonna make
yeah you don't mean it's gonna make that
I wanna do that more sometimes I feel
like I want to get into a fight with
somebody outside just to feel like I'm
interacting with somebody she's gonna
hit somebody yeah you know after the
fight I go thank you I just I needed
that I know I you like even like I just
even even some Klan members of some Klan
member was like yo he's stupid you know
to me he'll be late gonna talk to
somebody
yeah it's gonna be here I am I feel like
that that uh that ultra liberal hippie
white lady is in my experience also the
one of the only people that has
basically tried to ruin everyone's good
time at a comedy club you know oh dude
Wow you preaching to the choir now in my
experience and all my years of doing
stand-up the top 10 worst heckler
experiences I've ever had are always
women yeah I agree
just always and I don't know why that
happens I don't get it you know and then
but I will say this a portion of it is
because after the me to movement I think
the me to movement may
need a good comics great and mediocre
comics kind of like don't know how to
handle cuz we have to adjust you know
you adjust you know we all made
adjustments you know what I mean we all
like said okay well I still want to be I
still want to talk about misogynistic
topics but I just got to be more
thoughtful about it now in five years
you have to either change with it or you
don't you know yeah yeah so you know so
before that you might deal with a
heckler and there's things you would say
or like or maybe the subject you're
bringing up is inspiring this woman to
be so upset but now it's like but a lot
of times it is I don't know what that
mentality is that I don't know why they
always assume ill intent this is my
problem with it like we're at a comedy
club I'm gonna say something off pudding
you may disagree with it you may be like
not in like that one okay you know how
you don't like something like this yeah
that's it yeah I don't know why it takes
like a scene has to be made I mean you
just answered your own question because
the reason somebody doesn't just fit
through it is because they're arrogant
and entitled and they feel like they're
there is no place where they shouldn't
yell and interrupt everything going on
like think about the type of you just
have that as a prototype like when would
you do that I mean if I ask myself that
I just oh well I wouldn't I would just
[ __ ] sit there and not ruin
everything for everybody else you know
yeah I just I I always I always give the
example I'll go like like you might be
at a graduation and not agree with
something that's being said would let me
it up you know I mean you might be at a
play we're like if you were like that
same white woman at a play and there's
something off-putting between two
characters you wouldn't be at a play
like yeah in the comedy show they
definitely feel like it's fine
to do that and it's it's obviously I
mean like it's at this point we realize
it's just part of the job but yeah it's
hard not to hate them
I know it really I really like the one
that always says that to me is like when
this happened over the years a few times
is like when that person actually gets
mad for other people that's the one that
sends me over the top the most when
they're like yes you shouldn't have said
that and it's like not about them like
we talking about and then then there's
people who are the joke is about who are
like over here like oh no we're having a
good time
like yeah yeah that's a joke and we
that's what we're here for and you know
then this person is trying to dictate
how other people should feel that
they're like how condescending that is I
know they don't even they don't even
realize it
good be upset right now I think I can
handle my own feelings Thanks yeah I
think I got this don't you know I know
it's like I remember like I like like if
I if I have a joke about somebody about
a wheelchair in a wheelchair like I
stand by whatever I'm saying and if
there's somebody in the crowd in a
wheelchair
I would think that they'd be glad that
they're being oh I'm being included too
yeah like I'm not just some you know and
I just think that that's that's my
perspective but but I think people have
their own guilt they have their own you
know it's like when somebody goes oh I
mean you're just agreeing with me when
you do that you're making it worse so I
was gonna also wanna ask you um you know
it's like I so I heard about Michael yo
like you know Michael yo was really sick
yeah and I was just like damn that's
when it like the first time I really
like hit me like damn like cuz I always
think like comics were like roaches you
know to me like we got we have our we're
getting the germs from that dirty mic
like all over the country that I think
the mic disgusting right and sometimes I
see comics do some nasty [ __ ] where I'm
just like don't put that in your mouth
or like have you ever not even tried
tried but like unintentionally you're
holding it normally and you can smell
the mic oh you're like oh [ __ ] it's just
like a hundred dudes with bad breath
have been
hovering over it and you're like you get
you're holding in you're like holy [ __ ]
my mouth is right next to this [ __ ]
thing then it touches your lip you know
oh god I was at levity live in Oxnard
and I had to tell the guy afterwards I
was like yo dude like you need to clean
the mic clean it like that's been in
someone's butt hole it's so disgusting
know what I mean so I always felt like
we have like you know I don't get sick a
lot you know I felt like but this is one
of these things where you go you know
you'd want to be like well comics are
gonna get it but it's like damn is
touching everybody you know to me like I
was I was worried about myself I'm
worried about people like Bobby Lee you
know to me like Bobby's like a fat
little [ __ ] you know to me you know I
mean I'm worried about myself I work at
Burt I saw Joe Rogan talking about Burt
he was like man I'm worried about you
you know you drink too much he did some
now whatever so you know so I just feel
like I just eat Bobby seems like he
could be the origin facial I just mean
that he looks like he could be a month
at starts a lot of diseases yeah you
like Ground Zero
yeah the bird bird thing it makes sense
to worry about I mean the story about
Michael was so terrible because I mean
obviously you know he's a good guy and a
family guy and and to hear how sick he
was and then you go like this is a
healthy dude you know right I mean
Michael works out he's you know he's not
like a sloppy you know person who
doesn't take care of himself so you like
a guilty heads up in the ICU then you're
yeah it you know yeah that's good see
this is what I was bringing it up I mean
did did like what has made you like take
a second and like like the first week
like I have a friend of mine that's a
conspiracy theorist kind of guy who's
always on those kind of websites so two
months ago he was telling me like yo man
this virus is gonna be big you know you
know this already in China be careful
but boy like you know and I was like a
man shut up so even though someone then
finally I was like oh [ __ ] my dude was
right and then but even the first week
I'm like I think I'll be good I don't
think I'm gonna get it
but like now I'm at the point where it's
like all the news that comes out I'm
kind of like [ __ ] I don't want to get
this I'm really concerned what was the
moment for you that you thought to
yourself like this is like really real
like it's really touching you I mean I
got I'll be honest I'm I'm the whatever
the opposite of a conspiracy theorist is
is me um so like I I I've never gotten
to the point where I feel like I'm in
grave danger because of the way that you
know I follow I follow the stats I
follow the data and I know we're lucky
look California has managed this thing
really well so I just have told myself
that I don't really have any danger of
getting this if I'm smart about how I
write my life you know I mean like I
don't I mean it it's a scary thing don't
get me wrong it's a scary thing but I'm
not licking doorknobs you know I've gone
out for essentials we do have by the
city's mandate permission to go to our
podcast studio so I've gone there to do
podcast but we have a essential staff
only so we have what like three people
there right right and like you know we
we just make sure everybody's like
taking care of themselves and I mean
look it's it's a it's a serious threat
but I think like if I look if I was in
New York I think I would be in much more
of a panic because I agree does it good
mystics you know yeah I mean and Michael
was in New York before before he got
okay I didn't even know that I haven't
talked I'm trying to get him to come on
and talk to me about it because it's
like it's such a big did not the weekend
before I think I think although the
twelfth and thirteenth probably I don't
remember the exact dates and maybe it
was the week before that but yeah I
think I think the story was that he was
there flew back was sick and then you
know when to the haha but I friend of
mine been in a panic about this yeah
yeah but yeah yeah
why I just got only panic I'm in about
is like I mean if I'm it's just a
selfish thing for me I'm just in a panic
about like what's what's my business
gonna be like you know I'm just thinking
about my future I'm thinking about like
you know am I gonna be driving uber in
like two years like you know I don't
know I just thought those are the things
that go through my head I try not to
think like that but I always think like
that every time I don't get a job every
time I'm not working I'm like oh god
that was it for me might be
entertainment career is over now like a
natural sort of disaster is making me
feel that way
dude I have thought in terms of like
work how because every time like you
know I guess at first this was like just
your things getting delayed a few weeks
or a month and now to think of it as
like a three month or six month or maybe
even a year long thing I go you know
that's that's what I do I mean I know I
do podcasts and stuff too but I don't
consider myself a podcaster first right
I know exactly what you mean I know he's
like it's like it's like a marketing
tool to help other parts of our business
everything is just to get people to come
to shows yeah and so now we're just like
now we're like what are we all trying to
be Howard Stern now you know I mean like
that's like is that the end all now it's
like it's such a weird bizarre feeling
like I worked so hard to get what little
I have and now I feel like it's just
have you thought about this like I was
telling somebody that you know the
longest I think since I started doing
Stan at the longest I've gone without
doing stand-up there's probably
somewhere in like the two week you know
maybe two and a half weeks or something
though I've already already eclipsed
that right I met the the record now
you're right me too me too
right so I was thinking for a while it
was like let's say shows come back in
June right you've had a few months off
it's gonna be strange you'll be strange
for everybody then you go back on but
what if there's no stand up for like two
years something like that yeah here's
the thing there will be some people who
just go like yeah I just don't I'm not
gonna do stand up again yeah and I'm
booked that's weird
I'm like oh yeah like you just you would
ha at it so yeah they're like they're
like I made a good run or but but think
of all those people who were like who
were just trying to do it anyway who had
like two jobs to support their stand-up
habit and then you know those jobs are
gone because now they're like there's
just a lot of people were stand-up
itself beats you down and drives people
away ever every year anyway right yeah
now you have this on top of it yeah I
can't even imagine there's so many like
you know when you do stand-up there's
like there's so many tears tears yeah
that you go through it like I'm thinking
of this right now happening and how it
would affect me at those different tears
you know because if you had if you had
just started it's actually the best case
scenario cuz you're like right that's
right I just got a taste of it but man
if you were if you were just if your
momentum have just started to get I know
you maybe you're featuring or you're
like you know you're starting to get you
got your t-shirts that you like you know
you got you got 300 t-shirts in your car
that you think about this think of all
the ones that like didn't start a
podcast when they should have probably
and now they're trying to do it now they
are you know and they're just like hey
in its like it's just not the same I'm
so glad I started when I did you know
this is this will be like episode 79 for
me or something like that you know so
I'm just getting into it but I'm so glad
that I did you know you have the
foundation it's already a thing it's
like I know there's people scrambling
right now to start one and yeah that'll
be that'll be a challenge I mean some
some will thrive obviously but it's hard
it's already a chance a challenge for me
at this level that I'm doing it so I
can't even imagine being like somebody
with like say no notoriety at all like
you know you know you know they're just
like oh I'm funny and so I'll get it'll
catch fire on YouTube but I read a
statistic to just like it takes six
years to really start to catch get a
thing going on YouTube you know for a
regular but like
I think for some of us it was like we
already had some things going on TV
appearances special so we had a little
bit of a following so this is easier but
like just for a regular person you know
I don't know this space out there I mean
there's there's YouTube channels that
like they just do they do weird things
and you go I can't believe that they
have a million followers like there's
there's there's YouTube channels that
like dwarf comedian channels oh and it's
and it's just like nonsense stuff you
know electronics how to work your camera
opening a box of toys right right right
so there's room out there but I just
can't and we're just talking about
comedians because we're comedians and
it's just like thinking like my god what
what are people gonna do you know what I
mean it's devastating yeah
March 12th was my birthday and I was in
a row thank you I was in Tennessee at
the comedy catch 112
that's a Chattanooga yeah so I'm in
Chattanooga is so funny like they they
put you in this like they put you in
this condo okay yeah and I when I got to
the condo
I'm already little I'm nervous about the
corona [ __ ] and then there's a sign that
says please wash your own dishes I was
like I'm out you know what I mean
like you think I'm gonna trust comedians
washed dishes hell no you know I mean I
was like I don't you know we're so
spiteful and resentful of staying in
condos anyway that people put their
balls and stuff and I've heard horror
stories right yeah so I got a hotel I
got the hotel I paid for it out of
pocket yeah I was working the weekend
well and you state like they didn't
cancel the shows or anything no no
because this is one of those little
clubs were this affects them like
they're not a chain like this is this
guy's whole business man doesn't that
Club cuz I did a one-nighter there and
it was a few years ago I remember I
think I pulled the guy aside you know I
want to say near the bathroom there's a
sign that said like you get three
warnings and that's it and your I was
like hey dude is this for real
he was like yeah I go three words he's
like absolutely and then that's it I go
why would you give so many words
yeah yeah
I was like why isn't it one warning so
that it's a warning and then you're out
and he's like oh no you can't do that
and I was like yes you can't you can
you're gonna die
amen I'm gonna come back here two more
two more times
now did is funny you say that cuz I had
a situation that weekend with some
people you know I was just thinking and
then I'm looking around and I'm going
yeah but you're are you read a comedy
club like in the past cuz you're in a
different situation now but like you
read these comedy clubs were like you
look out and you realize there's no
security you're in a weird city by
yourself and then you're looking at a
table of people who hate you and you're
thinking to yourself anything it
happened to me right now course you know
what I mean
yes I mean I I think about one incident
to where I was doing a and I get I got
mad at myself because it was like it's
like a lesson that I learned where I was
20 minutes into like a Friday night or
Saturday night show it was completely
packed and I was just riding a wave like
I was rushing and in that like in that
environment of crushing I looked at it
one table that's and I saw like three
people stone-faced and I have learned I
learned it that night like I would never
do it again but I stopped I stopped what
I was doing to be like oh you're not
having a good time if [ __ ] went so
sideways but not only did everything go
sideways and terribly that when things
got really combative with them I'm
sitting there like I keep I'm on mic
like talking like who is going to get
involved with these people and I'm
seeing staff walk by and I'm like hello
dude
so after the show I'm like why the [ __ ]
didn't you do anything and they were
like what do you mean I'm like when I
was fighting with that table like I
never noticed that
like what like the whole show stopped
and they're like I never saw it I was
like yeah they just they don't care they
just worried about their drinks and
their things you know but I hated myself
for like you know like you could have
just you could have ignored those faces
and like kept yeah with the show but
that's just a comic thing I know I
stopped the show to be like why aren't
you laughing like oh yeah it's a we can
see a roomful of people killing we just
die in laughing and there's one person
with their arms crossed and after person
we [ __ ] fixate on that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what happened
you know but just per capita just
percentage-wise not everybody in the
room enjoying what you're doing you
would think you know to me like it's
just there's probably 10% of people who
are like I don't want to come to this
but my girl is a fan or yeah yeah oh
whatever it is right all right
extrapolate that to the public that's
wide but you also you also like you
learn it more with with a age and
perspective you also don't know that
like when you see that face you don't
know what that person went through that
day you don't know what's on their mind
is something weighing on them from work
from home are they exhausted are they
drunk are they high are they sad this
like I know it's you know what isn't
that the amazing thing about what we do
anyway a live performance like if you
think about it here we are trying to
wrangle you know 250 people who don't
know each other don't look alike
different economic social backgrounds
and we have to somehow make them all
agree yeah it's pretty amazing so it
shouldn't be surprising that yeah it's
not a hundred percent was just like you
know it makes me real like one time I
don't know if you ever like I was kind
of like you know am i a real fan of
anything like a super fan there's things
I like and I was kind of like beating
myself up and then I realized that
without kind of stopping and saying it I
realize I am like a super fan of comedy
of stand-up like I I love watching great
stand-up I love got you know I mean like
I got into this because I'm actually a
huge fan of it you know that what was
there a point that was there a point
that you like got back
that because there's appointment we're
coming up and we're trying to do it that
you're you know you become a little
jaded yeah no well I I I I think I'm
both I coexist with both things at the
same time I don't I mean I do have
bitterness and and like you know and I
would say I'm a bitter person but I'm
saying I have that like grumpiness to me
and like I'll be like I don't want to
watch comedy or anything like that but
when you put like a great comic onstage
in front of me and and just point me to
watch and they're really talented dude
it's the most enjoyable thing to me like
I yeah
I look I think that's why I was drawn to
it you know yeah I agree I agree I I
know I know exactly what you're saying
so I find I think I had that duality in
me too I feel like like I could sit in
the back of the comedy store sometimes
and be like oh I'm really enjoying this
person that I know and I'm like oh
that's like I love this how this is
working and we get so intellectual about
it too in our heads sometimes you forget
to like just enjoy the laughter I think
I'll probably I think we'll all kind of
be reinvigorated with that yeah you know
I know we'll have to sit through like
like how many months of you know just
hack quarantine jokes do you think are
gonna be out there like you know we're
gonna go the comedy stone it's just like
you know it's like you know every comedy
is gonna be like in well quarantine this
is what was happening with me it's like
let's add your joke and then just add
during warranty warranty
Ronna jokes somebody told me they like
aren't you excited that you'll be doing
you'll have all this material and I was
like what are you talking about thank
you my thought was I was like yeah all
it's gonna happen is like you're gonna
have to watch everybody's stuff to see
that thing on each other and there'll be
a bunch of horrible [ __ ] you and also in
these last few weeks I have not had a
funny thought about this come to mind
yeah I know exactly what you mean I know
and I find my I find myself as being one
of those people that can make anything
funny I believe that about myself you
know
but it's just like I just the only thing
that I have now is that my girlfriend is
Jewish and we had a zoom seder with her
family and hilarious that every just
everything that was happening with her
family on the screen and what they were
doing and just like I was dying that's
unique see that those are like the ones
where you go that's not gonna be the
reason it's so first of all you can put
a hundred comics on stage and they did
not have a zoom seder so you know what
you know what don't you'd be surprised I
mean but well here's the other thing
though you're not Jewish right right I'm
not but what makes it funny is that
you're an outsider witnessing that
that's what makes it unique like there
will be people who zoomed with their
families but less people who zoomed a
religious you know dinner with something
that they're not indirectly involved in
I think that's what makes it like
interesting to watch like it'll be your
commentary on all that right right it
was I wanted to record it but I couldn't
like I needed everybody's permission
recorded because this is gonna be like I
could have just done an episode about it
I could have been my Seder reaction
episode just was so funny so I don't
know I just I mean I'm we're talking
about standing up it's making me right
now just I miss it like I realized how
much I miss it like - like a week ago
every day around nine ish is when I
started to feel something because this
is the time I'm like I gotta get ready
to go to the comedy store yeah and I saw
so I I needed that I was like oh [ __ ] I
didn't realize how much that was a part
of my life like how religiously it was
like a religious thing that you just go
every I five times a week I'm doing this
you know it's just it's just it's just
strange to like but you know hopefully
hopefully we're gonna get back to it you
know I just you know I want to go to
movies I miss going to move I was a
movie person like on the road you know
that's where I saw my movies my
girlfriend's super sensitive so like if
there's if there's any violence on the
screen she just like oh yeah you know
yeah you know so like I have to go to
all those movies by myself and that's
what I do like
I got my AMC pass you know I watched
yeah yeah doing the movies on the road
is fun III do it to men yeah you know I
ask you this like I didn't realize how
peaceful it could be to eat and go to
movies by myself until I started doing
stand-up yeah yeah cuz cuz before that
it was like I felt oh man what a loser I
have to have somebody go with me no I
mean I do you know I'll go to a fancy a
steak house on the road by myself with
some headphones on iPad on the other
seat you know just just challenge out on
a rib eye like a like a king it's so
enjoyable nobody nobody's getting on me
about the butter I'm putting on there
it's just so it's like I just uh when
will we get back to that I miss going to
restaurants man I miss sushi I miss
Korean barbecue I miss you know I mean
like when's the restaurant business
gonna come back cuz there's they're
trying with this you know oh do delivery
delivery but I know that unless some of
them can't stay open I know some of them
can't keep going that's that's a real
bummer I mean yes I am a big restaurant
enjoyer as well and it's been it's been
heartbreaking to see like restaurants
that you I love clothes or they're
happen that party swing swingers closed
down for good and I used to go there
like I mean years had that was the spot
like after the store people go to
swingers this is sad yeah it's real sad
yeah that was like where can we go after
this that that's still open and fun and
that was that was a spot man I know well
look man I don't want to keep you any
longer we've been talking for a good
amount of time and I do I do appreciate
you doing this and please guys you know
make sure you watch ball hog it's on
Netflix right now it's going strong and
I hear it it crushed right he has some
good numbers they say they said it did
well I'm happy to hear it
I'm try not to ask too many questions
yeah yeah yeah just like Betsy here no
we all seen that we were saying we were
but uh one of funniest guys out there
mr. Tom Segura and I'll talk to you soon
buddy I enjoy talking with you thanks
brother you too man thanks for doing it
all right
all right take care